in 1927 29 of the top physicists
gathered at the prestigious solve
conference in brussels the only woman in
attendance was marie curie she had a lot
of firsts she was the first woman to win
a nobel prize the first person to win
the nobel prize twice and the first
person to win in two different fields
curry was best known for her work in
radioactivity which would save a million
lives during the first world war but
would ultimately take her own marie
curie was born maria salamaya swadovska
in warsaw poland then under the control
of the russian empire on november 7
1867. she was the youngest child of
teachers her mother brana suava
swadovska was the head teacher of a
prestigious boarding school for girls
her father vladislav swadovsky taught
physics and math and was proud of his
polish heritage as a result of his
patriotism his russian supervisors
forced him into lower paying positions
he also lost his savings through a bad
investment to support their five
children they had to take in student
borders this would be fatal maria's
eldest sibling her sister sophia caught
typhus from one of the lodgers and died
a few years later when maria was 10 her
mother died of tuberculosis the
tragedies caused maria to give up
catholicism the faith of her mom and
become agnostic her father wouldn't
forgive himself for losing his family's
savings however his children would
remember him as the man who nurtured
them emotionally and intellectually
maria finished high school at the top of
her class but wasn't allowed to attend
university because she was a woman the
russian empire banned women from getting
a university education so she and her
sister bronislava or brania for short
enrolled in the secretive flying
university or floating university in
warsaw named after the ever-changing
location of classes to avoid the
watchful eye of tsarist authorities her
sister then left for medical school in
paris maria hoped to eventually join her
the two made a pact maria would support
her sister's studies in paris and brania
would return the favor in the future so
from the age of 17 maria worked as a
governess tutor and also studied in her
spare time while working for relatives
the zorovskies she fell in love with
their son cashmere who would become a
mathematician but the zorovskies didn't
approve of her because she didn't have a
penny to her name it was said that as an
old man cashmere would sit
contemplatively before the statue of her
in front of the research institute she
went on to found
in 1891 when maria was 24 she finally
had the means to join her sister in
paris and now used the name marie she
enrolled at the university of paris
known as the sturban where she studied
physics in mathematics at first she
lived in the home of her sister who was
now married but later opted to rent a
little attic closer to the university
she often stayed at the heated library
until closing rather than spend the
evening in her unheated room her earlier
education had been insufficient so there
was a lot of catching up to do she
sometimes worked so hard she forgot to
eat and would pass out despite the
difficulties marie marveled at her
freedom writing it was like a new world
opened to me the world of science which
i was at last permitted to know in all
liberty she earned a degree in physics
and then another in mathematics she
planned on returning to poland but then
pierre curry came into her life he was
eight years older a well-known physicist
and an outsider who was educated by his
father and his teens they were
introduced by a mutual friend who knew
marie needed lab space for her research
and pierre headed a laboratory at the
school of industrial physics and
chemistry where engineers were trained
marie would say of pierre he had
dedicated his life to his dream of
science he felt the need of a companion
who could live his dream with him and he
hoped that companion would be her but
marie turned down his marriage proposal
since her plan was to return to her
native country however she learned that
it wouldn't be possible to start a
career in poland when she went back to
visit her family during summer break in
1894 krakow university denied her a job
as a professor because she was a woman
pierre convinced her to come back to
paris to pursue a phd she insisted that
he too get his doctorate which he did
pioneering research on magnetism they
married in 1895 at the town hall in
seoul in the suburbs of paris partners
in life and in science marie wore a dark
blue outfit on her wedding day that
would become her trademark in the
laboratory they bought bicycles of the
money they received as a wedding gift
their way of relaxing in a life
otherwise filled with research marie
curie would earn her doctor of science
degree from the sarbun in 1903. she did
her thesis on radiation which was
recently discovered in uranium by ahri
becquerel curie was intrigued by
begeha's discovery and investigated
further she used an electrometer
invented by her husband and his brother
to measure radioactivity in many
substances and materials she realized
through her experiments that radiation
was a property of the element of uranium
yet when she observed the mineral pitch
blend which primarily contains uranium
she noticed it was far more radioactive
than uranium could explain
how could this be it would only be
possible if there were something else in
the pitch blend pierre was so intrigued
that he dropped his own work to join her
in her search they ground up tons of
pitch blend and discovered an element
that was 400 times more radioactive than
uranium polonium named after her country
of birth and then they discovered
another element that gave off 900 times
more radiation than polonium radium the
unglamorous work of extracting and
isolating the elements took place in a
leaky and drafty shack near pierre's
work as they didn't have a dedicated lab
space their efforts paid off the nobel
prize in physics in 1903 went to marie
pierre and becker hell for their
research in radiation french academics
originally proposed that only pierre and
bequerrell received the prize leaving
marie out a sign of the times however a
sympathetic member of the nominating
committee swedish mathematician gyosta
mita leffler alerted pierre to the
situation he insisted that his wife
share the honor marie curie became the
first woman to win a nobel prize she and
her husband were too busy with their
research to accept the award in person
in stockholm pierre was also sick
suffering from pain and fatigue they had
no idea at the time that radiation could
be detrimental to their health it is
said that marie would carry tubes of
radium in her pockets she was fascinated
by what she described as faint fairy
lights little did she know this was
slowly killing her the glowing green
radium captivated the public it would be
a key element in early cancer treatment
and would also find its way into
everyday products toothpaste with the
promise of benefiting teeth and facial
creams in the belief that it would fir
muscles and smooth out wrinkles the
element was so popular that in the 1920s
a single gram of radium cost more than a
hundred thousand dollars well over a
million today the curies could have
tried to patent radium and cash in big
time but they didn't marie declared
radium is a chemical element a property
of all humans
after their groundbreaking work it was
pierre who would be promoted as head of
the physics department at the sobun yet
he still didn't have a proper lab pierre
complained and the university relented
however he would never get his dream of
working in a new laboratory because
tragedy struck less than two years after
the birth of their second daughter
on a rainy day in april 1906 pierre was
walking across the rio de fine when he
was run over by horse in carriage he
died instantly pierre's father implied
that his son's preoccupation with his
own thoughts contributed to his death
marie was offered his academic post to
the serpent instead of accepting a
widow's pension she became the first
female professor in france hundreds of
people lined up outside the university
hoping to attend her first lecture the
period following her husband's death
would be the most difficult of her life
in 1911 the french academy of sciences
the gathering place for prominent
scientists rejected her from membership
when she put herself forward for a
vacant seat they passed her over for
physicist and inventor eduardo brownlee
many suspected it was because she was an
immigrant and a woman despite getting
snubbed by the academy she went on to
win something even greater later that
year a second nobel prize this time in
chemistry for the discovery of polonium
and radium the isolation of radium and
the study of the nature of that
remarkable element but the buzz around
her wasn't great the french press was
all over her affair with her husband's
former student physician paul longeva
who was married but estranged from his
wife she was labeled as a homewrecker
and even warned that it might be best if
she didn't pick up the prize in person
curie sank into a deep depression only
to be slowly pulled out with the support
of a fellow scientist albert einstein
struck up a friendship with curry at the
first sylve conference in 1911. he wrote
her a letter of encouragement during
this dark period i am impelled to tell
you how much i have come to admire your
intellect your drive and your honesty he
then told her to pay no mind to the
stories in the press simply don't read
that hogwash curie went to stockholm to
accept her second nobel prize and the
headlines about the affair eventually
blew over she would slowly recover and
was in the middle of setting up a giant
laboratory at her newly created radium
institute when war broke out as german
troops headed toward paris she took her
stash of precious radium to a bank vault
in borundo in southwestern france the
new capital she also tried to sell her
two gold nobel prize medals to help the
war effort but the national bank refused
to accept them she would buy war bonds
using her prize money but this
self-sacrifice wasn't enough for her she
was determined to use her research to
save the lives of french soldiers she
had studied the work of german scientist
wilhelm runtgun who had discovered
x-rays curry then brought x-ray machines
to the battlefield by inventing mobile
units called little curries to help
surgeons locate and remove shrapnel and
bullets from wounded soldiers she and
her daughter irene trained 150 women to
drive these little cars and drove one
herself despite the danger kiri also
oversaw 200 radiological rooms in field
hospitals it's estimated that by the end
of the war her efforts saved the lives
of a million men but may have cost her
her own curry knew that overexposure to
x-rays would pose risks to her health
but there wasn't any time to improve on
safety practices years later she would
die of aplastic anemia a blood disease
likely due to exposure to large amounts
of radiation over her lifetime despite
her humanitarian efforts the french
government never gave her any official
recognition whereas she was gaining
increasing fame abroad in 1921 u.s
president warren harding invited her to
the white house and gave her a gift of a
gram of radium to aid in her research
the french government was apparently
embarrassed by the fact that they gave
her no distinctions so before that trip
to dc they offered her the country's
most distinguished honor the legion
donaire the legion of honor she declined
during her later years she headed the
radium institute later the curry
institute in paris and opened another in
warsaw where her sister brania became
the director both her main major
research institutions to this day she
was already in ill health by then on
july 4 1934 curry died at the age of 66
at a sanatorium in the town of passi in
eastern france she didn't live to see
her daughter irene when her own nobel
prize in chemistry a year later for the
artificial creation of new radioactive
elements sharing it with her husband
physicist frederick julio curry was
buried at a cemetery in seoul the
suburbs of paris where she married and
where her husband lay in 1995 both were
moved to the pontiac in paris the
resting place for many distinguished
french citizens like victor hugo russo
and voltaire curry was the first woman
to be honored in the ponzio on her own
merits her remains remained radioactive
so they were placed in a coffin lined
with nearly an inch of lead even her
papers are still radioactive today
anyone who wants to examine them must
wear protective gear and sign a waiver
kyrie's tireless work was surpassed only
by her fight to overcome the barriers in
her way to become one of the greatest
scientists of all time it wasn't only
her work that was impressive but also
her work ethic if you're eager to learn
more my sponsor skillshare can help you
learn new skills skillshare is an online
community with thousands of inspiring
classes on a wide variety of topics and
it's free to try out with the link in my
description youtuber and dr ali abdel
takes you through his secrets of how to
study effectively i would ask myself
does this make sense firstly and
secondly could i explain this to a
five-year-old there are classes on
everything from how to put a story
together from start to finish with mkbhd
how to edit videos and even how to take
professional photos with your iphone
what i really like is that each class is
broken down into short sections there
are no ads and no tests and again
skillshare is completely free to try out
for a month if you use the link in my
description thanks so much for watching
for newsthink i'm cindy palm